okay so zack snyder's justice league is
a film that fans had to wait a long time
for after suffering through four years
of one of the biggest downgrades since
mass effect andromeda the snyder cut not
only got the world's most expensive
shave out of our head but it also
improved the characters in several ways
there's a scene in the film that i think
perfectly encapsulates how powerful that
the league actually are as individuals
and though superman and wonder woman are
often seen as the only people who
actually do anything in the team zack
snyder showed us that every hero has
their own purpose nowhere was this scene
more than in barry allen's flash who
time traveled in the movie during its
climax to me it's an absolutely perfect
scene and it's completely mind-boggling
that warner bros actually wanted to cut
it from the movie because they didn't
understand it i'm not even kidding one
of the best scenes in the dc eu and
warner brothers thought it was a good
idea to get rid of it because they
didn't get what was happening well let
me explain in this video i'm gonna be
going through exactly why i think the
scene is perfect and how it not only
teases how powerful a flash is but why
it also sets up events for the future
that will have massive ramifications if
this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's more
than just a flash in the pan and if you
agree that this scene is amazing then
please smash the thumbs up button don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this each and every day and with that
out of the way let's get into this scene
now when i first saw it it completely
took me by surprise because i thought i
knew exactly how the movie was going to
go though we were promised a completely
different version to 2017's justice
league i was expecting the bare bones of
the story to be there and that we would
pretty much see the events play out in
the same way even though the acting
takes cinematography and well everything
would be better however my jaw dropped
to the floor when i realized that the
league were actually gonna lose unable
to separate the mother boxes we got a
scene which completely changed what i
thought was gonna be a predictable
ending and it took things in a brand new
direction
now at this point the unity was complete
and the world was about to be
terraformed into an apocalypse-like
planet which would render it a complete
wasteland this vision had been predicted
by cyborg when the league were about to
resurrect superman and for a split
second i actually believe that this
would set up the nightmare scenario
however something changed blast you had
been knocked out of action stood up and
he raised his hand defiantly to stop the
incoming wave this is something that the
characters symbolically did throughout
the movie and just before the car hit
victor stone and his mother he raised
his hand up which was murdered when his
father died too it's very much a gesture
put in place by snyder to show the
heroes defiantly attempting to stop what
is about to happen however whereas
victor failed the flash was able to tap
into the speed force at this moment and
completely change the events of history
flash healed himself at super speed and
then uttered the following words
just gotta go faster than the speed of
light far beyond the speed of light
gotta break the rule barry and you gotta
do it
in justice league flash had been used to
escort a russian family out of the area
here he was a god able to control time
destiny and fate as the character rushed
towards the unity i got goosebumps
seeing him race back in time as the
world rebuilt itself around him this was
an absolutely outstanding moment that
took him from being a secondary
speedster character to one of the best
of the best of the best so now watching
this scene back i think it's incredible
how as he races back to the source the
ground re-materializes at his feet as he
places them down what makes us even more
emotional is that the words of barry's
father play out as he goes back whatever
you want to be you're brilliant man
absolute best they're the best your kid
was one of them dad
one of the best of the best for you to
make your own future if you're living in
the past make your own future
make your own future
now this is because throughout the film
barry believed that he wasn't really
living up to his father's expectations
rather than watching him rot away in a
jail cell henry allen wanted barry to go
out there and make something of himself
this clearly weighed in on barry too but
this moment proved just how important he
was
and why he would never be a
disappointment it was very much
important for not only the world but
also the character's view of himself
now as he finally got towards the center
of the explosion the music really
started to ramp up and it made it an
absolutely breathtaking scene to watch i
completely love the attention to detail
in this moment and you can even see the
molecules reform around the characters
whose seconds before had been atomized
by the mother boxes as flash gets closer
to where cyborg is we can start to see
the character coming back together and
this includes his skeleton reforming
under his skin as the flashing muscles
layer over the top of it something else
that really hits home about this moment
is just how realistic that the cgi is to
my eye at least it's impossible to tell
whether this is a computer model or if
it's actually the actor himself and then
they've applied the effects over the top
of it either way it makes for an
incredible moment and it connects the
flash to another overlooked character
that is of course cyborg and earlier in
the movie we saw that he was in complete
command of every computer on earth and
that the character was a god on the
internet like your homeboy kevin
spoilers not much in the same way that
cyborg can control the stock market with
a wave of his hand flash could also
control time in the same manner and it
very much brought two of the most
underrated characters together and
showed just how powerful that they were
cyborg would of course go on to defeat
the forces of darkseid and after seeing
the league united in front of him he
decides to halt the invasion of earth
which of course wouldn't be possible
without the flash now because of this
moment we know that barry is one of the
most important characters in the dc
universe and realistically he's the only
person that can stop the nightmare
scenario that we see play out at the end
of the movie a version of barry of
course visited bruce in the cave during
the events of batman v superman and him
carrying out this action in the finale
let us know why it's so important that
he's there in the epilogue now this of
course has massive repercussions for the
future of the dc eu and we now know that
this immense power makes barry wonder
what else he can change in the
flashpoint comic book barry traveled
back in time to save his mother from
being murdered but this broke the
timeline and he ended up in an alternate
universe with a different version of
batman judging from what we know of the
upcoming flash movie both michael keaton
and ben affleck will be playing the dark
knight and this is likely because barry
was tempted by this power to go and
change more than just the events of the
steppenwolf fight his father was of
course in jail and the words he told him
rattled through his head as he ran so it
just makes so much sense that he would
go back and try and change things to
benefit his old dad now this is why the
scene is perfect to me not only is it a
beautiful piece of cinema that has
amazing music cgi and also
cinematography but it also propels a
person who was cast to the side in the
theatrical cut to the level of being a
god barry breaking his rule in order to
save us all also carries forth the
lessons that his dad tried to import on
him as well as the temptation that
having such a gift would cause if you
could change one thing for the better
surely you would try and do it in every
instance and i think that this is one of
the defining moments in barry allen's
life that will have massive
ramifications now it explains the
questions left in the air by the
nightmare scene in batman v superman and
also sets up a future in the dceu in
which barry will be one of the most
important characters it's a complete
redemption of a failed vision and if
we're reaching which we often are it
very much could metaphorically symbolize
snyder himself returning to fix the film
yes i set it to reach and that's why i
left it until the end of the video
either way though i think everything in
this moment is incredible and for me
it's one of the standout scenes in the
entire saga the scene is perfect and i
hope you've enjoyed me talking about it
as much as i have i would absolutely
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
running a competition right now and
giving away three mc box sets on the
30th of august and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the rat catches scene and suicide squad
which will be linked on screen right now
i absolutely love that scene as well and
you know i'm a channel where we just
like to talk about things that we like
so definitely go ahead over there right
after this if not then thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace